منطقه الحرب
والشروط بالامس
انهينا
مرحله وانتقلنا من الدفاع الى الهجوم في
الحرب من الحرب في منطقتنا الى حرب في عمق
منطقه العدو في قطاع غزه 100 يوم وصلنا
بالجهود الكبيره من اجل تحرير مخطوفين
وتمكنا من اعاده 110 منهم ونحن
سنجلب الاخرين وسنبذل كل جهود من اجل
تحقيق
ذلك وهذا الوقت ليس لان نجمل ولكن لننظر
الى الامام من اجل الاهداف التي يجب ان
نحققها في الحرب التي فتحت ضدنا يجب ان
ننتصر
بدون اي تنازل لا طريق اخرى الا ان نحسم
العدو وننتصر عليه نحن سنلاحق
ونصل الى كل من ضرب اولادنا واغتصب نسائنا
وخطف مسنين سنصل اليهم جميعا وسنقضي على
حماس وسنقضي على كل شخص من شارك في هذا
الحادث الاعداء والاصدقاء
سواء ينظرون الى نتائج القتال ونتائج
الحرب في داخل قطاع
غزه ينظرون الينا ويفحص ونا مستقبل دوله
اسرائيل
هنا على المحك ومرتبط بهذه الحرب العدو
الوحشي امامنا ما يجب ان يقوم هو الضغط
العسكري من اجل تحقيق اهداف الحرب القضاء
على قدرات حماس واعاده المخطوفين الى
الوطن هذه اهداف الحرب التي تم تحديدها
قبل ثلاثه اشهر وكانت جيده سليمه في هذا
الوقت وايضا اليوم عندم اذا ما توقفت
القتال فسيكون هناك قضاء على نتيجه على
المخطوفين في في اسر حماس بدون الضغط
العسكري لا احد يتحدث معنا بدون الضغط
العسكري لن نتمكن من ان نصل الى اي اتفاق
بمركز القوى يمكن ان نحرر المخطوفين
قبل ثلاثه اشهر عرضت مع رئيس الاركان
ورئيس الجهاز
والويه في جيش الدفاع برنامج الحرب في
قطاع غزه باورها الواسعه وفي المناطق
الاخرى امام مجلس مجلس الوزراء وايضا
اوضحنا ان العمليه البريه المضغوطه ستكون
لمده ثلاثه اشهر في شمالي قطاع غزه هذه
المرحله انتهت وفي جنوب قطاع غزه سنصل الى
هذا الانجاز قريبا وفي
هذين المكانين سنصل الى المرحله التاليه
نحن نوائي
نوائي في الميدان مع الواقع التي ترى
والانجازات العسكريه وتدمير
العدو وفي شمالي قطاع غزه تم تفكيك كل
القدرات اللوائي لحماس ونحن نعمل على
القضاء على بقيه جيوب المقاومه
وايضا نحن قوم بذلك من الجو بوسائل معينه
في مركز قطاع غزه نحن نقضي على الصناعه
العسكريه لحماس والمصانع مصانع الانتاج في
هذه الاماكن التي تنتج
فيها الاسلحه والوسائل وسائل القتل ضدنا
الانجازات كبيره جدا في جنوب قطاع غزه نحن
نعمل بطريقه مختلفه ق جيش الدفاع تركز في
راس راس الافعى ضد حماس هم يختبئون بعشرات
الامتار تحت الارض وخلال هذه العمليه ومن
اجل الرغبه في ان نضمن امننا ونعمل ضد
قيادات حماس نحن نعمل في شمال قطاع غزه و
جنوب خان يونس شمال خان يونس وفي كل
المناطق تم
تفكيك البنى القتاليه في في منطقه خانيونس
تتفكك القوه العسكريه لحماس هذه العمليه
تحتاج الى مراحل خلالها نحن نقطع المحاور
التي تؤدي الى خانيونس من خانيونس الى رفح
فوق الارض وتحت الارض كل يوم يمر مدينه
الارهاب التي بناها السنوار في جنوب قطاع
غزه تنهار شيئا فشيئا داخل الانفاق التي
تم
حفرها انا اقول هنا بشكل واض
في نهايه الحرب في غزه لن يكون هناك تهديد
عسكري من غزه حماس لن يستطيع ان يسيطر
ويعمل كقوه عسكريه في قطاع غزه ولجيش
الدفاع ستكون حريه العمل الكامل كيف يختار
من اجل ان يدافع على مواطني
اسرائيل هذا يمكن ان ياخذ وقتا طويلا ولكن
ينتهي فقط بالانتصار الحاسم في غزه
يعيش الفلسطينيون
وايضا سيسيطر الفلسطينيون في المستقبل
السلطه المستقبليه في غزه يجب ان تنمو من
داخل قطاع غزه وان ترتكز على القوات ليست
عدوه لاسرائيل وتشكل بديلا مدنيا تعمل من
اجل نمو مواطني غزه وليس ضد مواطني
اسرائيل نهايه العمليه العسكريه يجب ان
يكون منظم بعمل
سياسي الفكره السياسيه هي التي تقود العمل
العسكري عدم اتخاذ قرار سياسي يمكن ان يضر
بتقدم العمليه العسكريه وضعت امام مجلس
الوزراء برنامج ومسؤوليه الحكومه ومجلس
الوزراء ان تناقش هذا البرنامج كما ببرامج
اخرى وان تحقق ان تعين
الهدف
هذه الحرب هي حرب التصميم والاصرار ما
يميز
انتصارنا حت من المقاتل وحتى حكومه
اسرائيل هو الرغبه في الانتصار هذه حرب
حرب من التصميم حرب من المواصله هكذا فقط
يمكننا ان ننتصر اريد ان اتوجه من هنا الى
الشريكين الكبيرين في حكومه الوحده رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو والوزير بني جانس
واقول لهما هذه هذا الوقت للوحده
والمشاركه وهي التنازل بيننا من اجل ان
نحقق اهداف الحرب من اجلنا
جميعا
حكومه الطوارئ هي هدفها الانتصار في الحرب
وبدون هذه الحكومه حكومه الوحده يتحول كل
ثمن وكل انجا
حما ان نحقق وحده المحاربين في المعركه
والوحده الوطنيه المدنيه من اجل قياده
الدوله والسياسيه سنه 24 هي سنه حرب وايضا
ستكون سنه الانتصار نحن سننتصر
بها لاننا عادلين اكثر وننتصر لاننا
مصممون اكثر وانا ارسل من
هنا كلمات تاييد لجنود جيش الدفاع الذين
يعملون ليلا ونهارا على تنفيذ مهماتهم
وابناء عائلات المخطوفين التي هي في ظروف
صعبه و اتمنى الشفاء العاجل للجرحى وايضا
قلبهما هي مع العائلات الثكل والجنود
والمواطنين الذين بموتهم مم اعطونا لنا
هيا نحن ننتقل الى
الاسئله سيدي وزير الدفاع هل يمكن ان
تبلغنا معلومات جيده حول المخطوفين
وايضا الدعايه